hi everybody Welcome to the second talk
of today so our next speaker is Guy
Kindler and is going to talk about small
set expansion for the short photograph
so take it away guys
uh yeah so hyperconductivity or some
small set expansion so basically the
short code graph is a so this is small
set expander for a global set
and it's a mouthful so I'll just call it
sausage for now so the short code graph
is a social sausage and here is like the
disc of what uh nope
whole story so
some of the initial motivation at least
came from uh the problem of satisfying a
constraint graph so it's related to
computer science that's what I'm trying
to say you have like a graph and each
vertex can be assigned
an element of some finite subset and the
edges are constrained saying which
assignment to one variable
and which assignment to the other
variables are good well good together
and it's known this is the PCP com that
even if you can satisfy all the
constraints satisfy more than Delta
isn't very hard
this is well known uh and in O2 code
conjecture that even if the constraints
are one to one I won't describe what it
is then still if you can satisfy almost
all the constraints still satisfying
just Delta of them is and be hard that's
a conjecture
he also conducted something something a
little weaker which is that if the
constraints are two to two
then still it's and be hard to satisfy
even a doctor function when you can
actually satisfy everything
um
and then there's a long list of papers
that eventually resulted in in this sort
of proof of the 222 conjecture except
that instead of one it's a one minus
Delta uh so
[Music]
yeah so that's a proof of the 222
conjecture and this is this is a
code a mental
Safra the decays are the neuron Kindler
and this is a Barack cotarian story
um
yeah and
the current result is that we take uh
the last two results here and we somehow
prove it again but with in a more
generalized streamlined shortened and
conceptual way of men so that's
yeah so that was the short version a
little bit more detail there is
something called the gasman test it's a
consistency test of the code and the the
previous result
showed the 222 conjecture assuming that
this Glassman test works
um
and it turns out that for the test work
it's obviously required that The
Grassman graph is a sausage uh whatever
that means I'll say it later
and then we managed to prove a weak
version saying it's a some some sort of
a weak sausage uh and then uh and then
barakotari and Astoria proved that
actually if we prove that this graph is
a sausage then it's also sound and
therefore you get the 222
conjecture and then you cut and mincer
and suffer prove this that it's a
sausage
uh yeah so please move the 222
conjecture uh we prove that the shortcut
graph is the sausage and uh conveniently
install proved that if the shorter graph
is a social sausage then also The
Grassman graph is associated and
therefore the gasoline test is sound and
therefore
two to two is again pulled
doing but it's equivalent
yeah it's a crew yeah
um okay
um so yeah SSC it's the beginning of the
sausage so what does it mean to be an
SSD so we have a graph I'll say a graph
but it's actually a family of graphs
um
and it's an SSE if for every small set
so say the size of s compared to the
number of vertices is less than Delta
then if you start in a random vertex in
s and go on a random Edge Edge going out
of it then with probability 10 to 1 you
go outside of this so that's a small set
expansion
okay and one very good example of a
small set expander is the cube uh with
the graph of the noisy Cube so the
vertex set is just 0 1 to the n and uh
the edge it's not it's a weighted glass
so there's a distribution over edges
which goes by picking a random X and
then picking a y such that the ice
coordinate of Y is the ith coordinate of
X with probability table but otherwise
it's just random
um yeah so this is the noisy Cube
and here's a theorem
which says the raw noise cube is a small
set expander
and this follows easily from results of
bonami and also from results of Ross and
Beckner
um
and uh it's very useful this fact that
the small set expansion of the cube it
was used in
I won't say all the names so it was
useful Collective coin flipping for
showing that low influence functions are
juntas it was used for vertex cover
hardness and for showing that the
majority is the established
Global function and this resulted in Max
cut hardness and various various other
things it's very useful also in
combinatorics not just computer science
yeah so that's an important thing
uh but you don't always have an SSE so
here is a something that is not an SSC
not a small set expander the noise image
what is the noisy mesh it's very similar
to the cube except instead of zero one
to the hat and you have zero one two
three up to Q to the n and we think of Q
as something that grows uh
asymptotically with n
The Edge distribution is similar uh you
uh the English you pick X randomly if
you want to pick a random Edge and then
you pick y to be x i English coordinate
with probability Rule and otherwise you
just re-randomize it to pick another
random number between 0 and Q
so the whole noisy mesh is not a small
set expander and here is an example of a
small set that does not expand this is a
dictatorship so just take all the
elements in the cube whose eyes maybe I
don't know seventh coordinate is 17.
um it's first of all it's small so I
could Define something similar in the
cube but then it will be you know so all
elements so that their seventh
coordinate is zero but that would be
half the element in the cube that's not
small uh in the noise image it is small
because 17 is just one out of many
options
uh and uh yeah so its relative size is
one over q but probability of leaving us
if we spelled One S is a smaller than
one over one minus rho because
with probability although we don't
change x i and so we stay in the set
when you when we go on a random Edge
uh yeah okay so dictatorships
[Music]
such as this are not expanding but and
and you can generalize to Hunters which
are this term in not just one one
coordinate but but by several that they
do not expand but they are local uh in
the sense that they're defined by
looking at a small set of coordinates
uh so we can discuss non-local or is it
is called unfortunately Global a global
sets and functions
uh so what is a global set so here's the
function uh okay I was talking about
sets before but the function is just
think of it as a indicator of a set
uh it's two Norm is just the expectation
of the square of the value of the
function and uh yeah and we need to talk
about restriction so this restriction of
f on the coordinates of T to an
assignment why it's the function that on
X gives f of x y it's very a natural
definition here
and the set is the Epson Global if when
you restrict a d coordinates of f
to something to some fixed value then
the norm is still small the norm the two
Norm Square this skill is the Epsilon
um
and yeah and this this kills the the
example from the previous slide because
dictatorships even if you fix one
coordinate to 17 then the norm of what
you get is one because the indicator of
the dictatorship will always be one on
this restriction
uh so so restrictions
um yeah so so functions which are small
cannot be dictators
uh and it turns out that once you you
you only restrict two functions that are
Global that look like this and then the
noisy mesh is uh is a small set expander
so it is a small set expander for Global
sets so sausage
um so this was proved initially by
long
uh Norm lifted and though
yeah so we have the sausage property for
noisy mesh
and the among other things we also
reprove it maybe with slightly worse
parameters but with the same approach
with the same skin
um
and yeah and also we prove it for the
the Grid 2 short code graph which is
what gives the two to two thing
okay let's talk about the short code
graph uh I guess not everybody not
everyone knows it uh okay so I need
vertices and edges the vertices are the
linear functions
uh between F2 to the end to F2 to the M
for some n and M that I think of is kind
of large
we actually everything works for fq to
the n and fq to them but we'll stick
with two uh and instead of linear
functions you can just think of the
collection of matrices
and then an edge is between two matrices
if the rank of the difference of between
the two matrices is one so we look at
Matrix rank
and again this graph is not a small set
expander because of dictatorships except
that here we will need to redefine what
the dictatorship is so a dictatorship
one option is to look at the set of all
matrices that move a vector v exactly to
the vector W so that's a dictatorship
maybe call it the right dictatorship you
can think of a left dictatorship uh all
matrices that if you multiply by W from
the left you get V
uh so both of these are dictatorships
and what is the probability of escaping
a dictatorship so if you start from
maybe s
uh and then uh you look you look at the
neighbor of a so B is obtained from a by
adding a matrix of rank a one then the
probability of that uh that b also
satisfies this dictatorship condition
uh is the probability okay so I take a
and I add a rank one Matrix which is
just a product between uh two vectors
um
uh yeah so the probability is that a
plus this the rank one Matrix times V
equals a is just the probability that
sorry
yeah should be W that's true uh yeah I
mean so a times V is W so this needs to
be zero and among other things this if
this times V 0 then you're done and the
probability the distance V 0 is uh one
half okay so the Escape probability is
only one half even though it's a pretty
small set
so these are dictators and there are a
problem
uh but again we show that uh
for Global sets not dictators not
dictatorships this expands
uh
uh okay so again what are restrictions
[Music]
just like before or similar to before a
the Restriction is the Restriction to a
set that is defined as an intersection
of dictatorships are either left over so
a jurisdiction
is restriction to a d
uh dictatorships
uh and so once you have that you have
the definition of uh of uh at the
Epsilon Global function and we want to
prove that such functions expand or such
functions that are indicators of sets
expand
um okay so here is a
more quantitative version so uh yeah if
if you want if you get want to get one
minus two to the minus our expansion you
need out and two to the minus r squared
parameters of globality
uh and all can be whatever you want
so this is what we proved but what we
actually prove is a a
hyperconductive estimate or a norm
comparison estimate that says that if a
function
over this graph is uh
[Music]
is the uh
Delta Global then its phone ohm is upper
bounded basically by its two Norm uh
Delta is the parameter of the globalness
and this is think of it as a large
constant so
but this is not for the original
function it's only for its DW code
but that that turns out to be enough
yeah so you can think of it you can call
this estimate also a bonami Lemma
because bonami proved something very
similar for the Boolean Cube
um
and I need to tell you what a degree the
greedy function so is and one way of
saying it fast is uh is that it's a
linear combination of the should be a
dictatorships so of
a linear combination of products of the
dictation dictatorships
uh yeah okay and if you project F on
this space then this is f smaller
equality
uh okay and some few words on how the
proof goes before we go to the board uh
[Music]
we prove a
something that looks like this this is
rubbish it doesn't mean anything so but
it's somehow
uh but this is the gist of it uh
so we want to put we want to bound the
full Norm by the two Norm uh and what we
actually do is bound the full Norm by
the two Norm plus a lot of extra stuff
at least this is the first step and the
point is uh the and there are two points
about the extra stuff first of all
visual the pleasures whatever this means
and the property is that uh first of all
um
well they are not if f is of degree D
then these laplacians they are not
exactly of degree D but they can their
phone on can be bounded by the functions
of the grid that that is slightly
smaller than D so you can you can sort
of apply this again by recursion
and and really get a bound on the phone
Norm of F and when you look at these
smaller degree functions these smaller
degree functions are somehow related to
the restrictions of f so if if f is
global then you get these Norms of
functions that are related to the
sections of F and therefore their Norm
is also small
and therefore you manage to poop
something
um
right okay
and and to prove it first you have to
Define all these laplacians and and
influences and derivatives everything
that appears on the board here and this
turns out to be a very easy for the
noisy Cube
less easy but still possible for the
short code off
uh okay so that's that's the end of the
PowerPoint part
how do I
like this okay
um
yeah so this proof this uh this talk I
think will remind you of a lot of past
talks from from this week and maybe also
some weeks before
uh but
but yeah I'll still say a little bit
about how this uh how these Norm
comparisons relate to expansion uh so we
you have a graph G
and you want to say that it is a small
set
under maybe four small maybe for Global
sets so maybe just in general how is
this related to Norms uh
so here is a general scheme
okay there is a vertex vertex set and
there was a subset s which is small and
the function f
which is the indicator of s
um
and uh
we want to say something about the
probability of escaping s so it's like
we want
to show
that uh
if you take a random Edge if you take a
random X in v and then a random y that
is a neighbor of X
in the graph then the probability
that both f of x is one so both X is in
s and Y is in X that is this is much
smaller than uh
then the size of s which is
the two Norm of f squared
uh
right so this is what we want
foreign
okay and now
another way to write it is the
expectation over X in v
and instead of Y taking a random uh
neighbor of X and calling it y I write
it as f of x
times t g
uh of f
evaluated at X
and TG
of f
evaluated at X is just the expectation
of our neighbors of x
of f of Y
this is the graph noise operator
which we've seen many variants of
already uh
right so and this so this is just a
different way of writing the same thing
and this is
the inner product between f
and t g of f
okay and I want to connect all this to
uh Norms of low degree parts of f so I
need to Define these degrees so the next
step is to
right
if the sum
of parts of different degrees I goes
from
0 to however is appropriate
um
and
um yeah and this is
f equals I is the pure
I degree
out
of F and the way that it is defined it
depends on the graph that you are
working for with and the idea is that
you define these degrees in a way that
TG
okay
let's
think of f as the sum of the low degree
part just other the sum of all the I's
up to D plus the high degree part
and the idea is that these are
or the on the space of at most D degree
functions is an eigenspace sorry it's
not an angle space it's a
um what do you call a space that remains
uh
in Valiant yeah it's an invariant
in
variant
space
of TG
and same for the space of functions of
degree greater than D and if you define
the degrees correctly then uh t g
just kills
EG just kills the parts that are high
degree so this is going to be much much
smaller
than the norm of f
and so here you have
if inner product TG of the Hydra grip
out
plus F in a product with TG
of the loader grip out
and this this is basically zero because
TG kills the high degree parts and this
you have to deal with and similarly to
to what uh Noah mentioned in his talk
TG of the small part
is
it doesn't do much to the small part
it's basically the same thing
and therefore
here comes the norm estimation so so now
we want to bound this part
uh and this comes in handy if if you can
prove it if you can prove that the phone
Norm of this thing is bounded by
some constant maybe depends on the
times Delta in case we are talking about
global functions times
uh times times the two Norm
squared
if you have
um
then you can just okay
intuitively it just means that
the support of this function is sort of
spread because if it's if it's if it has
a really tiny support and and gets
really high values there then the phonon
will be much higher than the two Norm
uh and if their support is spread then
when you in a product it with f remember
f is a indicator of a tiny set then
you'll get something very small okay so
this is the intuition uh technically the
easiest way to to do it is by
doing a Helder so this is smaller than
uh
F smaller than d a phone ohm times
okay I
I forgot about the TG here right so uh
so this is f smaller than the phone ohm
times f
maybe four over three Norm
and then the four Norm can be bounded by
the two norm and if you work with it
right you get a bound showing that this
is much smaller than the two Norm of of
the original if okay so that's the
motivation for proving
uh bounds of this salt
um
uh
TG itself
to the other side and then replace f
with
also with f less than b and the left
side oh I could do many things it's uh
but you just let me just get the L2 Norm
of f less than b right you don't need to
go to
yeah but I mean I could if you wanted
this together yeah I I could I mean this
inner product even without the teaching
it's the same if I put F smaller or
equal to Dio because the different
degrees of orthogonal uh but
but somehow I gained because I I take a
norm of F that is not the two Norm it's
smaller than the two Norms uh I lose
because I put the phone only which is
louder but then I gain again because I
have an upper bound of the phone now
using the tunnel so I I need to go up to
the phono in order to get inside
because I mean this is one of the things
that you will just have to
do by yourself uh okay so yeah so this
is our goal probing
bounds of this form bonami type bounds
um
some of this stuff
foreign
all right so for the noisy Boolean Cube
we have a we have a bonami type bound it
was proven by bonami
and it says that the four Norm is
smaller than
something to the D
times the two Norm
uh
if
the degree of f
is at most D yeah
it's not invariant under scaling right
yeah that I needed the this one it is
because
Delta is two
um uh too homogeneous homogeneous of the
Greek too and this is also homogeneous
of the grito so
because Delta is a bound on the two Norm
squared of the restrictions of f so it's
fine but I agree that it's confusing
um
okay yeah so so for the Boolean Cube
we have it uh
for the shortcut graph
um
yeah what happens with the short code
graph we have
we're talking about functions from the
set of matrices
F2
functions from the set of matrices to O
um
how can you write such a function you
can write it as sum
of f hat
s times Chi s
okay
this you can do for functions over the
Boolean cube right Chi s is just the
product of the code the s coordinates of
x if you think of X as plus minus one
valued
but matrices over F2 I'm also just weird
vectors of length M times n just written
in a weird way so you could also write
that
for s that is a subset
of M times n
uh
right and then we want a similar result
why don't we already have it
but yeah that okay so so the point is
and this is why I had to do the the
intro about this degree things the
degrees have to work well with TG and TG
is different to you and so the degrees
are different so that so here the degree
the degree
of a character in The Boolean cube is
just the size of s
but here if we want it to work well with
the with the noise operator the noise
operator is corresponds to the rank of
matrices so the degree of a character is
actually the rank
of s when seen as a 0 1 Matrix
and this is why this doesn't give a
bonami bound immediately
uh
okay and I doubt that I will go back to
the short code again uh
I just wanted to you to know what a
degree is for the short code
so now yeah once you have a degree of a
character then the you can
take this sum and bunch it up according
to the grids
but let's talk about the
noisy mesh
well the noisy mesh
yeah we have F from Q to the n
to all
uh how do you
Bunch it up to degrees well you can
write f as the sum this is the F1 Stein
the composition so you can write f as a
sum of things that are you denote f
equals s for all subsets of N and these
things are all orthogonal uh and f
equals s depends only on S but also it's
orthogonal to anything that depends on a
subset of the coordinates of s
uh and that actually defines this and
then and then the degree
of
this F at s thing is just the size of s
um
[Music]
and then the claim is
that we want to uh that we want to prove
and then to use uh
somehow recursion to get a economic type
Lemma
the claim is that
if
all Norm to the full this is
or D degree
actually yeah so sorry yeah for d
degree function
it holds that its phone on is bounded by
some constant
times it's two Norm to the fourth power
Plus
so this is the straight up Cube bonomy
part the Boolean Cube plus all the rest
which is some
uh
yeah 4D
s
aplacian s
F also phone on to the full power
we're going over all pieces
yeah
all non-emptss
um
yeah that's how the markers get here but
then the return here in the next uh
thank you okay
yeah it's still it's still the phone on
phone on to the fourth power but the
idea is that this can be somehow
represented by lower degree functions
and then if you assume by induction that
you have this Polo degree functions
for the functions of the grease model
and D you can apply
again
I didn't Define the laplacian so for now
it's just a thing
um and I think my next yeah so the next
step is to Define
uh laplacians and the derivatives
yeah so yeah but this was sort of
General this is the scheme but for the
scheme to work and I need to Define what
laplacian zero are for my particular
graph
this is nine to the D because those yeah
yeah nine yeah
okay there will be no queue anymore
okay
foreign
the s
the blessing of f is the sum
of all
elements of the iPhone stand the
composition of f
for T's that contain s
um
and
um and there is another thing that I I I
said the name of but I didn't actually
write on the board there is something
called the derivative
of f
my derivative has s but also has X
uh
and this is a function
of Y so X is actually in okay now there
is a Q This is q
to the S so it's a bunch of coordinates
it's an assignment for the coordinates
of s and the derivative of s at X
evaluated for f
okay whatever whatever is here in the
mode it's defined by the laplacian S of
f but evaluated
at x times y
so it's the Restriction of the laplacian
2X
and
and the point is that
once you took the laplacian it only
contains ft's
with these that have elements from s
actually have all the elements from s
and now if you fix coordinates from s
then each such element has a lot of its
coordinates fixed and therefore it
becomes something of a much lower degree
so that's the ID
yeah and uh right and the the
inspiration from all these definitions
come from the Boolean cable these are
actually derivatives
um
all right so you could write
yeah so when I had before maybe it's
still on the board you have the four
Norm squared of the laplacian it's
actually just
the expectation over X
chosen randomly from
an assignment to the s coordinates of
this phone ohm squared of the derivative
of f
and these things are already of a
smaller degree and so you can recalls
over this uh
so okay so for now I'm just telling you
how once you get the claim you could
recurse right because at least in
general yeah you have this laplacian and
then you write it as an expectation of
four Norms of derivatives and these are
of smaller degree and you assume that
for this you already proved something
yeah
the degree rather than on the end
standards the induction is
a function yeah yeah the induction is
under the degree of the function so this
is these are functions of smaller the
great so for them you can apply the
the inductive hypothesis and
is it is it clear why the derivative
degree of the derivative is smaller than
the function like the way you define it
well f equals T is a function that
depends on the coordinates of t Okay uh
and and okay but T has to be of size at
most D because F was a function of the
Great Mouse d
D and then you fix some of the
coordinates
uh
good so yeah so if you do the work
you get something like four known
of everything smaller than some terrible
constant times the starter expectation
of f or S sorry sum over s
of
uh
expectations over X's or the two Norm of
derivatives
uh
pronoun
to the fourth power
because I applied the recursive
inductive hypothesis
and the point is that these derivatives
now you know you have to look at the
definition but it turns out that the two
Norms of these derivatives are small if
you know that F has uh small
restrictions
okay so okay so the real question is how
to get this thing
uh
so let's talk about that
um
okay
so I want to bound
the phone ohm to the full power this is
just the expectation of f to the fourth
by the two Norm squared squared again
plus whatever is left
um
yeah so let's let's say something about
how this is obtained
foreign
went through some operator stuff
so here is the basic idea from
bonamiskov if we look at the
tournament squared of f
uh
for the Boolean Cube It's just effort of
f h s squared like the square root of
the Fourier coefficients come over
everything
uh
this can be written in a way that's also
relevant for the noisy mesh just look at
f equals s
non-squared sum overall f
so
if you look at the tone on a
squared squared then that's just
well you have to just square that so
it's a sum overall s and all t or maybe
a light over T1 and T2 of f equals T1
Square this is just uh opening
parenthesis f equals D2
you know to
go out to squared right so that's the
fourth Norm sorry that's that's the
fourth power of the second Norm but it's
the fourth Norm of a function
uh the fourth Norm
right I want to know it because I want
to compare these two things the fourth
Norm of a function
is the expectation of its fourth power
so it's the expectation over X of f x
squared squared
uh also known as the second known
squared
of f squared
uh
so now I have the second known squared
of something and I can use the formula
from above so this is just the sum over
all s
of
the the equals s part of f squared a two
non
Square this is just completely
mechanical
um
right uh okay now what is f squared
uh let's just write it down
foreign
this is sum over s
uh I have the norm here 2 squared
of the S part
of f squared so F squared is just a sum
over a T1
okay f is just
the sum of f equals s over all s so if I
Square it I get all the mixed products
so I get
uh f equals K1 times f equals T2
okay and this is okay and this is just a
completely mechanical uh computation now
I need to ask myself okay if I have a
set T1 and I have a set T2 what is the
degree as part of this product okay and
the answer changes depending on what set
I'm looking at so for the Boolean Cube
uh
f equals T1 times f equals T2
this is just
maybe you'll like it better if I write F
hat of T1 times F hat of T2
1 times F at of T2 of chi of the
character of T1
symmetric difference D2 that's what
happens when you multiply characters of
the over the Boolean Cube
and then what does it contribute to the
degree to the equals s part well it
contributes nothing unless T1
symmetric difference with T2 equals s so
for the Boolean Cube
uh this just equals sum over s over sum
over T1
a symmetric difference T2 equals s
of a
yeah so the the the so so you just get
to the two Norm of this
which is a effort
T1 effect
T2
squared also you can write it as
f equals T1
squared f equals T2
okay so this was this was the cube and
now we have two uh this is
Summerville
T1 and T2 which sum up to S and now we
have this expression
for the fourth Norm of f squared and we
have this expression for for f two Norm
to the fourth power and you just uh
you just do the computation it's a
computation with numbers it has nothing
to do with operators or functions you
can just show that this is bounded
by some
um constant times f
2 squared
so this is the Boolean Cube
right to the
yeah okay
sorry
nine yes because I took it to the fourth
power yes
uh okay good so okay so what
this is the Boolean Cube what happens in
the noisy mesh
well two things happen
one is that
um
yeah so you you have all these pearls T1
and T2 some of these pearls look like uh
in the Boolean Cube though uh the
symmetric difference is equal to s
uh
and from this it can it is easy enough
to show that the if you only look at t1s
and t2s such that
the symmetric difference is s
uh
if you look at the two non squared of
this uh this is bounded
by the Sun
over the same pearls
uh
of a yeah and I have the sum over s here
and then you get
f equals T1
squared f equals T2
pronoun squared
to BS
okay but this is the same thing that we
got here
and because of the same number in a game
this part is bounded by the sum okay so
these are look at these Justice number
so this is uh bounded by the sum over
essays of x equals s
normed squared
squared which is
which is just
the two Norm squared square root of f
Ash this is for this is for the mesh but
only when I sum over t1s and two twos
that have the same structure as in the
Boolean Cube so uh yeah and and again we
have this nine to the Dio so this is a
so so uh
yeah I already erased what I wanted to
get but I wanted to bound uh the fourth
Norm squared of f by this plus some some
stuff that remains okay so I I got this
but I only took into account certain
pairs of t1s and p2s so the question is
okay yeah but what happens to the other
t1s and t2s
uh
okay so which other t1s and t2s
contribute to the to the equals s part
when T1 symmetric difference T2 equals s
exactly it means that T1 covers uh some
part of s and T2 covers all the rest of
us
and on the outside they maybe contain
other things that cancel
uh
if they do not cover all of us
then they will contribute nothing
uh to the degree a spot
that's pretty easy to see
so the rest of the stuff that I need to
worry about is when T1 and T2 do cover
is
uh but
um yeah so what if they do cover is but
they cover with overlap
and that's the only part that I need to
that's the only remaining part that I
need to bound
uh
[Music]
uh right so yeah so but but what I claim
is that if I look
uh
yeah but if I look at the part
well T1 and T2 their intersection
contains something from s
it's not empty even inside s
uh of the same thing
okay my claim is that I can bound it
by looking at
uh
the placidans
so I need
Poonam
is not outside
so uh
uh I see no yeah no light
it doesn't matter because I'm going to
use the the triangle quality
which doesn't hold but it holds if I add
another factor of nine to the D or
something
so yeah so I'm going to I'm going to
push the norm inside and multiply by 9
to the D
and bound each of these terms or the sum
of these terms by the sum of the
laplacians T of f
uh
but okay I bound it by
yeah this
is like this
uh
and okay so why why can I do this bound
because l t of f
or t containing this so now think of t
as the intersection of T1 and T2 and S
for this intersection section A LT
contains all of the f equals T1 and all
the f equals T2
41 and T2 that contains this that
contain this thing
so yeah so when I take this laplacian
Square I get all these terms
uh yeah and that's uh about it so I I
abandoned terms that do not intersect in
s in one way and then and there is it
tells that do intersecting us I bounded
using the square square of the
laplacians and uh yeah and I have
you get this
uh yeah so this is the two non squared
of the laplacian squared when you sum
over all s it turns out to be some
yeah so when you sum up also over s
I will just order a plus ones
fall down to the foreign
main idea
foreign
so it's just a computation on
yeah I I can't find anything now on the
boat but uh
you have
yeah the the the
phonon squared you get it by summing
over s
and then uh
uh
summing oval the product of the squares
of these Fourier coefficients
and if you just compute the two Norm
squared
uh yeah what is the difference actually
uh
the difference
yeah
okay I cannot just uh do it like
formally but the difference comes from
the fact that there are triangle
inequalities that you need to use uh you
get Norms of
sub functions and and you want to say
that they're bounded you know you get
the two Norm squared over sum of things
and you want to say that this is smaller
than the sum of the two Norms squared of
the things inside
and uh
and the two Norm Square does not satisfy
the triangle inequality so you have to
multiply by the number of terms that you
add and so you get some some exponent in
D because
because the number of terms that appear
they'll depend on the number of ways to
partition s into two uh
two sets that do not intersect
yeah so it's yeah so the yeah so maybe
you maybe it's not nine maybe it's a
four to the something what
no so it's I think okay I don't remember
but it sounds I think it's
okay to be honest nine to the day is
what you get from vacuums inequality
so I think if you do about an amazing
equality you get something that more
examples something that you'll get from
Counting subsets of this or more a lot
more like two to the deal fall to the
deal eight something like that I don't
remember
if you want to say something
because it's optimal okay so maybe
I don't know something you'll get
something
[Music]
so there's some sort of mesh for the
other place that's right no it doesn't
reduce to this it's just they followed
the same skin uh so you need to redefine
what laplacian is
and actually it turns out to be more
tricky than the multiple ways in which
you could Define a laplacian because
here at laplacian is just the sun over
ft 40 containing s but if you look at S
as a matrix what does it mean for where
another Matrix to contain the original
Matrix well
definitions that you can try and
actually we need more or less all of
that
so yeah so there is a laplacian and you
have to define the derivative the
derivative and the derivative of a
derivative here it's just the derivative
some some of the derivative of the
derivative is just the derivative it's
it all works well and then when you get
when you try to do recaution and you
find you have derivatives of derivative
derivatives they don't work so well
together and so you have to write them
again as some other like you know
combinations of other kinds of
derivatives so yeah so the skin is the
same and if you're tenacious
if you go at it enough you will make it
but but everything works a little bit
slower
yeah maybe yeah maybe you can even the
one conceptualism
[Music]
any more questions
do you get uh
I think so right
everything is
uh all right so there is yeah and and
it's sort of a known to click it's uh uh
BK cake if you've added enough case to
be okay
yeah okay yeah originally yeah
originally back in there and also ghost
wanted to yeah so all these uh this
great stuff
in the beginning was seen as a way to
prove stuff things on the on the
continuous space
they looked at the gaussian space
if you want the solid cube it can also
work but in a different techniques here
and what those
yeah so there's not a degree for the
Matrix case ah so
let's make some little
somehow unique Fourier transform the
rank fund functions it does it it has to
Decay with the rank of the frequency is
that
yeah yeah right yeah so yeah so it needs
to be yeah it needs to be a an
environment space and it also needs to
and you also need the highest degrees to
vanish when you apply to them and that
will not uh yeah it will not work with
the usual the notion of the group
okay so with other time so expect any
further questions of time and let's
think that again
[Applause]
we'll see you after lunch at two